hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of our readers Gordon who runs
an auto shop and has partnered up with
an equipment company to create new
technology that can help auto shops
across the country become more
productive and he's looking for help in
selling it and one of my advice on how
to find salespeople to help him grow his
business so Gordon Congrats on the
opportunity it sounds really exciting a
couple of ideas for you first off you
may not be strong at sales but you might
be better at marketing and that might be
a skill set you could tap into to help
grow your company and get it off the
ground so by marketing you're creating
content you might be taking a
pay-per-click advertising you could be
speaking at trade shows or getting in
the media creating videos like this
you're basically creating a whole bunch
of content to get people to find out
about you and then once they're calling
in it's a lot easier to sell them on
whatever technology you're selling so
that might be a way you can go without
having to go get a salesperson so get
your company off the ground and get
those first few orders rolling in if
you're dead set on finding a sales
person two things I would think about
first off you want to find somebody who
has industry experience so you don't
look at somebody who's not brand new to
the auto industry you want somebody
who's done it before
and somebody who you get along with
right if you're bringing somebody on new
in the company especially if it's just
gonna be the two of you at the start you
want somebody who you're gonna be able
to get along with so to find this person
I would start looking at who's currently
selling to you already you mentioned you
own an auto shop in your email so where
are you buying from right now and who
are the vendors and who are the
salespeople who are approaching you do
you like any of them do you get along
with them you think they're really good
at sales because it's a sell into you
they're probably selling to your
competitors and auto shops you know
across the country as well so that could
be a good person to start with the
second type of person I would also look
at is some the trade shows so you also
met your name when you go to trade shows
so look at the trade shows and see who's
selling there those are all sales people
at trade shows so is there anybody who
resonates well with you who you think
could be a good addition to your company
now if you're bringing on a salesperson
you have to think about compensation it
was just a two of you you probably can't
afford to pay a huge salary and usually
salespeople don't take Commission only
type of positions at a star
company so you might want to think about
the equity side and how they're gonna
get compensated and when you bring in an
equity partner on there's a lot of
potential issues if you don't get along
down the road so definitely making an
earn in so they have to reach certain
milestones to earn that equity in the
business so Gordon I hope that helps
Congrats on a new opportunity good luck
with it sounds exciting and if you like
the video and if everybody else liked
the video please give it a thumbs up
below I'd also love to hear feedback if
you only have a comment those things
make me want to create more of these
types of videos so please leave a
comment below and stay tuned to the next
episode
you